hello and welcome to the 22nd financial
plotting tutorial within Python and
matplotlib where we left off we created
a function for computing the exponential
moving average now what we want to do is
create a function for using the
exponential moving average to compute
the MACD so and actually like all of the
MACD so the way that we're going to do
that is with another function of course
and that's going to be define and
compute MACD and our parameters here is
going to be X you know for the data and
then we have the slow line and we'll go
ahead and define them but obviously you
could change them later and then fast
line 12 and that's it therefore all the
parameters that we need the next thing
we want to do is let's go ahead and
remind ourselves what consists of or
what the MACD consists of so the MACD
begins with you've got like a MACD the
actual line of the MACD and that's the
12
EMA - the 26 next you've got the signal
line and the signal line is the nine EMA
- or I'm sorry it's the 90 M 802 Magni
line and then finally you've got like
the histogram so a lot of people do it
with bars but we're not going to use
Barger and then use like a line and a
filler but you I you know the probably
the proper way is with bars I just don't
like them is going to be the MACD line -
the signal line okay so just a reminder
about what's going on with the MACD so
now for our function of the MACD this is
actually probably easier than the moving
average was or the exponential moving
average but the way that we're going to
do this is where is a EMA slow equals x
average and then we want to use X and
slow so it'll be like the 26 basically
and then we're going to do a make fast
and I think what we'll do we'll just
copy your pace they'll save our fingers
and typing work smart not hard fast X
tests and then finally what we want to
return is going to be um a slow EMA fast
and then EMA fast
- EMA slow and that should return us a
the all three parts toward MACD chart
that we need actually well then we'll
also have to do the expert the nine
period exponential moving average but
that will just call down there and we'll
just do you know this function with it
so that covers the creation of the
exponential moving average so now I
guess what we would want to do is let's
make the space for that MACD chart so
let's scroll down here and we'll add it
I guess we'll put it right down here so
to do this we're gonna say I'll see what
kind of ranges are we using at the
moment
five five let's make this a actually
trying to think let's bring this up real
quick
so well working with yeah we've got no
space so we definitely need to make some
space so we'll make it a six by four and
just kind of run through it real quick
six five four
that was a shared access I think that'll
do it give us some space at the bottom
yep okay so now what we want to do is
define our you know ax to only stop the
program
Runyon so ax 2 is going to equal PLT dot
subplot to grid and it will be working
with a 6x4 it's going to start at 5 0
its guys share the x-axis of AX 1 it's
going to row span one rope and it's
going to column span four columns and
it's gonna have an axes background see
if we can find it here we go this right
here scroll back down axis background
paste awesome
and let's just see what we got now I
might not be able to see it something
we've changed in these vines but you can
tell it's there because it blocks out
all this stuff nice so I think what
we'll do is let's go ahead and add all
the spine information here I think what
we can you take this
make sure copy/paste we don't want this
you want this paste paste paste paste
and paste save it ready see what working
with net cool okay so now we've got the
dates here we do have these dates that
we want to get rid of notice we'll do
that and then maybe arrange those
correctly and then we'll continue on in
the next video so close out of that and
stop the program and now what we want to
do is where is that function where we're
aligning stuff here it is so get rid of
this you know for labels and ax1 come
down here now we're going to do for
labels and a x2 now we want to do is
come down here and we'll just do this
same thing or a x1 that run that see
what we've got now all right looking
good we've got a little overlap here but
we'll deal with that later we'll just
trim the upper okay cool so now what
we're ready to do is call that Mac the
function and actually plot it on there
and I think in the interest of trying to
keep my videos a little bit shorter than
they've been running I'm gonna cut the
video here and continue on in the next
video so hopefully you guys are looking
forward to adding the MACD to your chart
and really kind of completing your chart
a lot of people this is exactly the
chart they always plot so it's kind of
cool when you can do it yourself so as
always thank you for watching thanks for
your support your subscriptions until
the next video